[Music]
c-sections are the most common major
surgery performed on human beings
over basically one generation of moms
the c-section rate has gone up by 500
the problem is that your number one risk
for having a c-section might be which
hospital you go to
that's what wakes me up in the morning
[Music]
i'm neil shah an obstetrician over at
beth israel deaconess medical center
i'm an assistant professor at harvard
medical school and i'm part of the core
faculty here at ariadne labs
a lot of people don't realize the full
magnitude of the problem with c-sections
basically in the late 1960s early 1970s
c-section rates were about five percent
and then all of a sudden the c-section
rate starts to skyrocket not just
increase but skyrocket so before the end
of the century when a c-section rate
goes up to one in three
and we don't really have a great idea
why this is happening
as a surgeon myself it's hard to believe
that one in three human beings needs a
major surgery to be born but that's sort
of where we are right now and the
consequences are significant so things
like severe infection hemorrhage organ
injury in addition to five billion
dollars of spending annually we're
talking something like
20 000 major avoidable
surgical complications that we're seeing
from c-sections we didn't need to do in
the first place
i was really puzzled when i first
started this job thinking like what can
we possibly do about this
epidemiologists economists policymakers
lots of people have been thinking about
this for a long time the clue for me was
the fact that across the country
c-section rates vary from 7 to 70 by
hospital
if hospital performance is so uneven and
it's not explained by patient risk or
patient preference that means the
hospital itself could be a risk factor
all of our projects right now are
actually trying to figure out what makes
hospital a different from a hospital be
what we've seen is that oftentimes the
labor floor is in kind of like an almost
forgotten about corner and it just
doesn't get a lot of investment or
attention from the hospital
when we visit a bunch of different
hospitals we realize that they're laid
out very differently and that might
matter
for example there are no rules for how
many labor floor rooms you should have
based on the amount of patients that you
see the place that does twice as many
deliveries also does way more c-sections
the only way that's possible is if
they're moving people through much
faster almost all labor floors seem
really tight on resources so the idea is
when you have a huge surge in patient
volume how do you flexibly recruit more
rooms how do you bring in more staff do
you report c-section rates
back to your doctors like i have no idea
what my c-section rate is until somebody
tells me you know we're testing this
hypothesis that management matters and
childbirth just the way it matters in
every other industry
starting to parse differences among
c-sections so rather than looking at all
c-sections altogether we're trying to
just take the lowest risk women and
focus on their c-section rate
as soon as you start to do that two
things happen insurance companies start
to pay attention and then just women
start to pay attention and i actually
think this is an area where women's
views on this are probably going to be
the driving force behind the change
there's really no other moment in
people's life where they're so
discerning as when they become pregnant
[Music]
you